[Musique]
vous m'aidez à supposer que je fasse ce que nous faisons pour
moi quoi que ce soit
mon nom est Katie Mary bee Cuddy vaut
mr.  Bon sang, je vis et généralement seule une
fois que trois femmes dans ce pays ont
perdu la raison,
nos maris ne peuvent pas s'occuper d'elles
correctement, vous et moi allons les
ramener de l'autre côté de la rivière vers l'Iowa, c'est votre
travail que vous avez juré de faire c'est pourquoi je
vous libérer trois femmes folles pendant cinq
semaines il y a beaucoup plus que ce que j'avais
négocié car votre voyage sera long,
difficile et dangereux attendez-
vous à ce que vous n'ayez que trois types de personnes ici
vous n'avez pas besoin de wagons qui ne
veulent pas voir  des fous me suivent des
cargos et vont sûrement te violer et
tu vas partir les indiens vont
te tuer tout ce qu'on a
[Musique]
on forme une bonne équipe toi et moi
toi